A
TURTLE.
>> Harold: A "WASHINGTON POST"
COLUMNIST IS SLAMMING THE
COMEDIAN IN AN OP-ED.
THE FORMER HEAD OF THE CDC NOT
BACKING AWAY FROM HIS BELIEF ON
WHERE COVID CAME FROM.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S PLAUSIBLE
THAT THIS VIRUS WENT FROM A
BATCH TO AN ANIMAL WE STILL
DON'T KNOW THAT ANIMAL.
AND THEN WENT INTO HUMANS AND
IMMEDIATELY LEARNED HOW TO BE
HUMAN TO HUMAN TRANSMISSIBLE TO
CAUSING ONE OF THE GREATEST
PANDEMICS WE'VE HAD IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
>> Harold: SOME SAY YOU MIGHT
NOT OF BEEN TELLING THE TRUTH
AND HE MAY HAVE BEEN JOKING, YOU
HAVE A GOOD HANDLE ON COMEDY,
WAS HE TELLING THE TRUTH?
>> Greg: THE BIG REVELATION
HERE IS THAT JON STEWART WATCHES
FOX NEWS.
IT MAKES SENSE, HE'S NOW IN OUR
AGE GROUP WHERE THE WISDOM KICKS
IN OR MAYBE HIS WRITER BECAUSE I
THINK, WHEN I SAID, THERE'S A
FIREWORK EXPLOSION IN A SMALL
TOWN, YOU CHECK THE FIREWORKS
FACTORY AND HIS WRITER WROTE, IF
THERE IS A CHOCOLATE EXPLOSION
YOU CHECK THE CHOCOLATE FACTORY
SO I THINK THIS WAS SO SHOCKING
BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN A BUBBLE
AND THEY HAVEN'T HEARD THIS
OPINION WEARS YOU'VE HEARD THIS
OPINION AND OTHER OPINIONS HERE
ON FOX, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
THEORY, WE'VE DONE SEGMENTS ON
IT BUT IN PLACES LIKE "THE VIEW"
WHERE THE ONLY INFORMATION THEY
GET IT FROM "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE
THEY ARE LIKE OH, MY GOD, IT'S
SO AMAZING.
ANYBODY WHO'S SHOCKED BY THIS
REVEALS THE IGNORANCE OF THE
ACTUAL TOPIC.
>> Harold: DANA, YOU KNOW,
WHITE HOUSES HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND WHEN BAD THINGS HAPPEN
TO MAKE SURE WE ARE PREPARED.
I'M ASSUMING CHINA, YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME THE WORST CASE.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO ASSUME THE
WORST AND CHINA NEEDS TO KNOW
THAT WE ALL ASSUME THE WORST.
IF THIS WERE CALLED THE MOSCOW
VIRUS AND IT ALL STARTED IN
MOSCOW DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD
BE RELUCTANT TO FIND OUT THE
ROOT CAUSE AND HOW THIS VIRUS
GOT UP THERE?
TO DR. REDFIELD'S POINT, ONE OF
THE BIG PROBLEMS EARLY ON IS
BECAUSE CHINA WASN'T OPEN ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON HERE WE WERE
TREATING HIM OF THE CDC WAS
TREATING THIS AS ANOTHER SARS
OUTBREAK, YOU TREAT SARS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THAN YOU TREAT
CORONAVIRUS THE WHITE HOUSE OR
ADMINISTRATION IF THEY DON'T
HAVE CLEAR INFORMATION YOU ARE
GOING TO TREAT THE WRONG
PROBLEM.
THAT LED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR LIVES AND THEIR
LIVELIHOODS AND SO YOU WONDER,
LIKE, WHEN IS THE LEFT GOING TO
GET MAD.
>> Harold: SPEAKING OF THE
LEFT GETTING MAD, JESSE?
>> Jesse: DID I MAKE THEM OUT
AGAIN?
I THINK THIS IS FUNNY, IT'S
COMMON SENSE BUT IT'S SAFE,
WE'VE KNOWN FOR A YEAR IT LIKELY
CAME FROM A LAB, BIDEN NOW SAYS
IT'S OKAY TO TALK ABOUT, FAUCI
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
CNN SAY IT'S OKAY TO TALK ABOUT.
BOLD, THIS IS EDGY, HE WENT
THERE.
HE DIDN'T GO THERE, THE GUYS
RETIRED, THE ONLY REASON HE
MAKES A JOKE LIKE THIS IS
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T WORK FOR THE
CORPORATE MEDIA.
WHEN YOU WORK FOR THE CORPORATE
MEDIA YOU CAN'T PLAY AGAINST THE
NARRATIVE.
THE NARRATIVE WAS THIS CAN'T
COME FROM A LAB BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SO MUCH MONEY OVER THERE
INVESTED IN BEIJING.
TIME WARNER, AT&T, COMCAST, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO SEND A TEAM OF
INVESTIGATORS OVER TO THE WUHAN
LAB AND START POKING AROUND,
THERE'S TOO MUCH AT STAKE, THE
CHINESE WILL JUST TAKE AWAY
THEIR LICENSE AND THEIR DEALS
UNDER CONTRACT AND IT'S OVER SO
YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY SOMETHING
THAT'S OBVIOUS IF THAT IS --
GOES AGAINST THE PROFIT MARGIN.
LOOK, THEY DID IT COME OF THE
TYPE OF GUY AND MIDNIGHT IN
BELOW FREEZING TO GO OUT FOR A
SUBWAY SANDWICH, YOU SAY THAT
AND THEY CALL YOU A RACIST.
OR WHAT ABOUT KAVANAUGH.
THE CHINESE, ARE THEY REALLY
GIVING HUNTER BIDEN A DIAMOND
BECAUSE THEY ARE BEST FRIENDS?
IT'S A BRIBE.
IF YOU SAY SOMETHING THE
CORPORATE MEDIA DOESN'T LIKE
THEY WILL EXCOMMUNICATE YOU.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT ANYMORE BECAUSE HE'S
RETIRED AND HE WORKS ON A FARM
NOW.
HE HAS A LITTLE FARM.
>> Greg: NO WONDER THE BEARD.
>> Jesse: YES, HE'S IN
CHARACTER.
>> Harold: WATCH OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY BE URGING
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO DO WITH
CHINA?
BE FINE WITH ANY COMPANY WANTS
TO DO THIS IN CHINA THEY ARE
CARRYING WATER FROM XI JINPING
AT ALL AND THAT'S WHAT SO
DISGUSTING AND YOU'VE SEEN IT
WITH THE COMPLETE RETICENCE TO
CALL OUT HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES IN
CHINA SO GREG, I HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE TO YOU, I THINK I
STOLE THAT LINE FROM YOU, TOO.
>> Greg: WE SHARED THE SAME
THOUGHTS.
>> Dagen: MY TAKE ON THIS IS,
THIS IS JON STEWART BEGINNING TO
RECLAIM COMEDY IN A WAY THAT --
IT'S BEEN HELD HOSTAGE BY
THEN-SKINNED LIBERALS.
>> Greg: I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Greg: YOU CANNOT WRITE
JOKES THAT LAND AROUND THE
MICRO-SENSITIVITIES OF LEFT
WING NUTS.
HE MADE THAT GUY'S CAREER, SEEMS
TO BE SPIRALING DOWN THE TOILET
BOWL GIVEN THE LACK OF LAUGHS ON
THAT LATE-NIGHT SHOW BUT THERE
IS NOTHING FUNNIER THAN A COMIC
RIDICULING, KNOCKING THE
STUFFING OUT OF A SOUR,
ARROGANT, SELF-IMPORTANT
BLOWHARD.
JOAN RIVERS DID IT, THERE IS NO
BIGGER SOUR, SELF-IMPORTANT,
ARROGANT BLOWHARD THAN
STEPHEN COLBERT AND JON STEWART
DID IT RIGHT IN FRONT OF THEM,
BASICALLY IN HIS FACE AND I ATE
IT UP BUT I WON'T BE WATCHING